technically supporting our action in a
few moments care of Cousteau will be
able to start life streaming and take us
to a unique trip you can screen the
divers are in the water and it will only
take us humans to be accompanied by
their unique equipment take us to it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
I start with some statistics about ghost
nets so everybody hearing us knows why
we're doing what we're doing today okay
great so according to scientific reports
you nap every year about six hundred and
forty thousand tons of fishing gear are
left in our seas and oceans the ghost
nets are so indiscriminate they killed
craps fish the fishing industries rely
on all over the world also sea turtles
dolphins any kind of marine animal they
chip over eight years
eight hundred and seventy nets were
removed from the coastline washington
state in the US for example entangled
were over thirty thousand thirty two
thousand mean animals ghost nuts make up
ten percent of the marine litter in
every ocean in one day
divers technical divers can remove about
three hundred kilos of ghostly from the
sea if we had the help of salvage
companies together with them we can
collect up to ten thousand kilos in a
couple of days so that's a big
difference
pierre-yves are you doing so this is
your first time diving with the team of
technical divers doing this chose
fishing is an organization with
volunteer divers from all over the world
who do this pretty amazing
we see you guys
you better
[Applause]
we see some fish
what are these lift bags filled with
[Applause]
[Applause]
pierre-yves can you tell us what the
difference is between a technical diver
and a recreational diver well
Oh
[Applause]
what are these
[Applause]
[Applause]
can you tell us what are the risks and
the benefits of removing these nets and
if there is a point you would say it's
better to just leave them there that's
also a question from Laura and
[Applause]
welcome
let me just add can I give some stats
about how much plastic is found in our
seasoned ocean well now I have it right
here period huh
I can do it right now and tell people
how much plastic is found in our season
ocean hurt so this these are amazing
figures just it's crazy to think about
so 140 million tons of plastic live in
our oceans and that is equivalent to 1
million blue whales an additional 12
million tons enters the ocean every year
80% of this plastic comes from
land-based activity only 3% of ocean
plastic is at the surface of the Seas
let's see okay so between 20 and 77% of
fish found in the world's market contain
microplastics over to you perry what do
you see now
[Applause]
but what depth are you now we are
currently a 25 minute
that looks like a massive net let's see
[Applause]
preparing a fire to limp back now what
what they're doing
[Applause]
so one more piece of information which I
think most of us have already read is
that according to recent report by the
Ellen Foundation by 2050 there will be
more plastic in the season oceans
can you tell us the difference between
the dry suit and the wet suit I actually
wanted to know this
diapers
and they are working let's see them in
fleet - lips
[Music]
we are right above you so we're gonna
see those lift bags in a minute now
we're sending the world
so for everybody watching us there is a
Twitter poll that you can take part in
just go to a Twitter page and answer
what is the maximum depth of the net
that we are removing today
careless signaling up get away from the
neck we're gonna move back
I have a question for you from Brad what
is your favorite sea creature he asks
organizing this event
pierre-yves I have another person
question for you from Tina how did you
face your fear of water at an early age
you have said that you were afraid of
water
Wow
now pendant isn't fighting it
a little bit
oh yeah
it looks like that one
oh really quite a thing up
let's backs have surfaced
[Music]
Oh
I'm counting six lift bags seven eight
coming up all right
[Music]
[Applause]
pierre-yves I think the most important
question Jim Shannon Hall and she asks
what can we do
[Applause]
we simply must do that Perry Brad over
here is asking me to ask you to let us
know when you're about to surface higher
than Brad the engineer he wants to know
when you're about to ascend
[Laughter]
we have to wrap it up here Eve so at
this point can I
I'd like to thank some people so helpful
see these ghost fishing and Cousteau
divers would like to thank the exclusive
sponsor of this been carpet go also all
of other supporters aqua fill seascape
cruise Association of Santorini
Santorini marine protected area
Association the primary school of via
the Port Authority of Santorini boatman
suddenly discovers now his foundation
[Applause]
also like to give a shout out
you